[Musique]
c'est le mot que redoutait d'entendre
les pays bas aujourd'hui confinement il
vient d'être annoncée par le
gouvernement il ya quelques minutes
après une réunion d'urgence à quel
moment le gouvernement lui va amener des
actions et des réponses fortes pour
aider l'épidémie puisque là ça se passe
à la laverie vous n'êtes pas sérieux
dire qui a pas eu de réponse forte pour
freiner l'épidémie en irlande le mot qui
fâche c'est couvre-feu explosion des cas
oblige fermeture obligatoire à 20 heures
pour les bars pubs et restaurants
je parle de ceux d'aberdeen avait des
stocks de masques alors que vous n'avez
pas non non non non jamais dit qu'on est
des structures s il ya une pénurie
mondiale et vous avez dit vous avez des
stocks de maintenant je me souviens
qu'il ya quelques mois le gouvernement
était contre totalement opposées nous
avait dit que jamais le mettre en oeuvre
le pass annie terre ça a été mis en
place il nous a indiqué que jamais au
grand jamais la vaccination serait
rendue obligatoire elle est en train par
une forme déguisée d'être rendue
obligatoire ce projet de loi sera soumis
au parlement début janvier notamment
pour transformer le pass sanitaire en
passe vaccinale celui ci ne pourra être
activée qu'avec une vaccination complète
et non plus un test négatif au covic 19
le passo tonale est une forme déguisée
de l'obligation vaccinale mais c'est
plus efficace qu'une obligation
vaccinale empêcher les gens d'aller dans
des bars des restaurants dans des lieux
qui reçoit du public s'ils ne sont pas
vaccinés c'est plus efficace que leur
mettre une amende de 100 euros quand on
les attrape dans la rue
cette mesure est une mesure à la fois
inutile vexatoire et et liberticide pour
rien la fuite en avant
de l'hygiénisme d'état qui cherche à
attraper ces erreurs par des manches ce
qu'il a dit c'est que c'était une forme
d' obligation vaccinale dès lors qu'on
renforce drastiquement on rend fou qu'on
transforme le pass sanitaire en passe
vaccinale faut bien comprendre que le
sens de notre logique c'est quoi c'est
de dire qu'on souhaite que les personnes
vaccinées puisse vivre quasi normalement
à noël
les concerts sont désormais interdits
les villes et et villages de france
annuler les festivités de fin d'année
faut arrêter de fermer des lits ou
pourrait déjà faire ça les tests
gratuits il faut organiser la société du
roulement c'est-à-dire que tout le monde
ne partent pas au travail en même temps
en 24 heures que moi je vais faire des
miracles et faire aboutir ce qui depuis
dix-huit mois piétine mais il ya une
obligation et c'est le sens et la
finalité de la politique de répondre aux
problèmes des gens pour cela j'envisage
d'être candidate à l'élection
présidentielle
de la république française
je ne serai pas une candidate de plus
je mettrai toutes mes forces dans les
dernières chances dé l'union pour
réduire le nombre de candidatures qui
est le diagnostic on rajoute des
candidatures à moment
par et et d'improviser la réalité c'est
qu'elle est à gauche une candidate de
plus on voit bien que la gauche
partisane qui s'est coupé du réel ces
dernières années est un peu perdu pour
l'instant il est moi qui ai un programme
non je ne veux nuire à personne je ne je
ne veux me disputer avec personne mais
je les prie d'aller s'occuper plus loin
la vieille gauche à mon avis est en
train de se
ridiculiser la scène se déroule près
d'un camp de fortune dans lequel vivent
des migrants à la sortie de calais
pendant plusieurs minutes les militaires
s'adonnent à des pointes de vitesse et à
des allers retours dans une immense
flaque d'eau avant de terminer leur
parcours coincé dans une ornière
les scientifiques l'espère aussi ils
sont optimistes depuis lundi le volcan
est entré dans une phase de léthargie et
les pompiers déblaient les maisons sans
relâche si cette inactivité se prolonge
encore dix jours l'éruption sera
officiellement terminé
c'est finalement un autre camion
militaire qui viendra les extirper de la
boue sinon total respect pour tout le
monde pas d'histoire battez vous encore
vous laissez moi tranquille